so the the role of the FBI is to enforce
the law correct
and you know there's a there's a limited
number of tools on our on our Batman
belt that we can use
um you know not to get into all the
aspects of the Trump case and Mar-A-Lago
and the documents there I mean the the
FBI has so many tools they can use and a
search warrant is the only way they
could get in there I mean that's it it's
a you know there's no other legal
document or legal way to enter and get
those documents what do you think about
the
the FBI and Mar-A-Lago and the FBI
taking the documents for Donald Trump
you know it's a tough spot I it's a
really tough spot the the FBI's got a
lot of black guys
um you know recently
um and I don't know if it's the same FBI
that I I remember when I was there do
you think they deserve it in part
was it done clumsily the the their
rating of uh the former president's
residence
yeah
um
it's tough it's tough you know because
again they're only limited to what
they're allowed what they're legally
allowed to do in a search warrant is the
only legal way of doing it
um I have my personal and political
views on certain things
um you know and and I think it might yes
it might be surprising to some where
those political
point stand but uh you told me Offline
that you're a hardcore communist that
was very strange very surprising to me
well that's only you try to bring me to
the Communist Party exactly I was trying
to recruit you it's giving you all kinds
of Flyers